[Musique]
exode games est une start up créée en
2010 est à montigny le bretonneux je
vous le disais allez spécialisée dans
l'édition de jeux de société et depuis
sa création elle a multiplié par trois
son chiffre d'affaires
[Musique]
et pour parler de cette réussite nous
sommes avec la dirigeante d'exode game
hélène barral bonjour alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut retrouver sous le sapin pour
ce noël 2020 cette année la plus grosse
annonce qu'on a chez exane games et
d'ego bnat nos petits gobelins favoris
notamment le petit gobelins qui était
offert à tous les ans pour noël qu'ils
perdent gobelins et panique une bière
pour les amoureux de parachutisme donc
ce dont sont des jeux déjà développé un
voilà ils sont produits ils ont très
bien marché cette année et ce sont des
choses qui sont pour les parents pour
les enfants et qui sont assez rapides
moins de 20 minutes 30 minutes si vous
êtes un peu un peu d'habitants mais non
le délai très rapide avec cette année
2001 très particulière une crise
sanitaire comment vous avez résisté à
cette crise les ventes ont aidés donc
les jeux de société ont été un des
succès phare de cette année plus que les
gens étant confiné ont développé un peu
plus leurs coûts pour les jeux les jeux
de société et du coup les jeux qui était
déjà produit ont beaucoup se sont
beaucoup battus ont fait des ruptures
aussi on a dû reproduire et par contre
ce qui a été plus difficile c'est pour
les jeux qui devait sortir cette année
qui ont subi les retards de production
notamment parce que du coup les
conditions ont fait que certaines usines
ont dû fermer aussi temporairement en
chine ou en europe que on n'a pas tout
le monde disponible dans les locaux pour
développer constamment le clae trail
peut-être aussi un frein pour développer
et du coup c'est eux qui sont pas sortis
cette année qui sortiront l'année
prochaine qui l'ont pris à peu près
entre six mois
entre trois et six mois de retard de
production et ceux qui sont en
développement également aux prêts à peu
près la même
le même temps de retard alors on était
venu vous voir en début d'année pour
votre produit phare c'est jurassique
couleurs de développer avec universal
comment ça s'est passé par rapport à ce
jeu du coup alors c'est lui qui a eu le
plus de retard puisqu'il malheureusement
il a besoin de trois entreprises
différentes pour être créés et donc ceux
qui font les moules des figurines
l'entreprise qui le fabrique en chine et
le transporteur qui le transporte
et du coup il est il a pris du retard
ils étaient prêts pour septembre et
aujourd'hui il sera livré en premier
trimestre de 2021 de janvier et c'est
lui qui a pris le plus gros retard mais
c'est aussi la plus grosse vente depuis
vous avez multiplié votre chiffre
d'affaires par trois cette année 2020
va-t-elle plombé un peu cette croissance
alors forcément on a subi un peu de
perte de croissance de perte de vitesse
mais on a dû aussi se serrer les coudes
entre éditeurs donc ça c'est quelque
chose que qui est très très commun au
milieu ludique puisqu'on est toujours là
les uns pour les votes mais on a décidé
de repartir d'encore plus belles l'année
prochaine donc avec la sortie de d'une
vingtaine de jeux l'avantagé au moins
d'avoir subi du routard c'est qu'on a pu
se poser repartir sur de nouvelles bases
alors avant de parler justement du futur
des prochaines sorties à un mot sur
justement cette collaboration commence à
ces faits concrètement cette
collaboration entre éditeurs ces issues
en fait de jurassic à la base un éditeur
qui m'a contacté en me disant qu'il
aurait bien aimé me apporter son aide
sur le projet parce que il en était fan
et sortir des projets
un ex dessus notamment avec la corde
universal et au fur et à mesure on a
apporté mutuellement notre aide
on a eu un gros investisseur qui a cru
en nous et qui a dit je me joins à l
aventure donc dans la société ge et la
sottise hyde et on s'est regroupés pour
créer bityeki sera oblet l'année
prochaine et qui du coup a prévu de
faire du transverse et permet d'aider
donc les jeux vidéo les jeux de société
et un peu d'autres surprises et donc
justement l'avenir est plutôt optimiste
pour examiner l'avenir est très
optimiste alors malheureusement
peut-être pas forcément pour la marque
exact games mais plutôt problème à
bitche parce qu'on a pris du coup à a
vraiment émergé pour devenir bichkek
mais l'essence même de bitche est exact
des médias et donc ya pas de hip hop et
tout ça ça se passe à guyancourt sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
merci et le baram rtm dirigeante de
exode
[Musique]